so hi everyone thank you for
coming to listen uh we are from lehigh
university and we're going to be talking
about our project
in stem learning through visualization
and that we have run through the office
of creative inquiry at lehigh university
and all the work we talk about today can
be found on
our website and all the code can be
found on our github repository link here
so i am anna marini i am a senior at
lehigh university and i'm studying
statistics
um my name is brian lucas and i'm a
junior at lehigh university studying
chemical engineering
um the advisors who are directly
associated with this project
are professor rangarajan from the
department of chemical engineering at
lehigh
um dr tiago rajan who
has been of immense help with us but he
is not
affiliated with the university in any
way and then the other
um person who has been of a men's health
to us is the late professor grossi who
is from the
um lehigh university chemical
engineering department
uh we also had some assistance from
people outside of our project
so dr angela brown dr laurie hurst and
professor bill scheissler are all lehigh
university professors
and steve anthony from the lehigh
technical services have all helped us in
some way with our project
so the reason why we took on this
project
was anecdotally speaking from my own
experience
stem subjects and people in stem majors
there is a
fairly low retention rate for people in
stem fields
so a lot of people tend to change majors
pretty early on
um you know who are studying some
subjects
and then with that there's also a
lack of access to experiences inside
labs
and so given the current situation with
coven 19
the accessibility to labs is even more
restricted
so by doing this project we're able to
kind of
enhance the students ability to
personally interact with material
and give access to
you know that interactive experience
that they might not be able to have
so so far we have three models that are
currently being hosted on our website
that people can access
the first model is a reaction kinetics
model for sequential reactions
the second model is a thermodynamic and
heat transfer model that deals with a
zero energy cooling chamber
and the third model that we have
currently hosted on our website is an
infectious disease model
that details the spread of an infectious
disease
so i'm going to walk you through our
infectious disease model a little bit
more
so it's an scir infectious disease model
which is based on a system of
differential equations
so for our model we have eight classes
and therefore eight differential
equations
and our classes are susceptible people
exposed and then we have four infected
classes
recovered and dead and the four infected
classes
we separated them out due to different
potential rates
so we have in asymptomatic and unknown
infected
in asymptomatic and known infected
symptomatic
infected and non-hospitalized
symptomatic infected and hospitalized
so when you open up the
sphere model on our website this is what
you see and on the left we have a
network graph
and on the right is a bar graph both of
the
class populations for each of the eight
classes
and then there's this time slider with a
pause and play button
so when the user hits the play button
the program will start iterating through
time and show how
each of the class populations changes
and the user can pause this and drag the
time slider to a specific value
if they want and these graphs also have
some interesting capabilities that we
are able to add so if a user hovers over
an
edge a description will pop out
describing how an individual moves from
one class to another along that edge
and on the bar graph the user can zoom
in
and they can hover over the bars to get
the current class populations
and then we also just have some
additional information below
so under the second tab which is a sort
of build your own infectious disease
where the user has the ability to change
different parameter values such as
infection rate recovery rate or
introduce a vaccine
and the graph will automatically update
to reflect these parameters and changes
so the top graph has all eight of the
class populations over time
and the bottom graph just displays the
four infectious classes to get a more
zoomed in look and then the table on the
right just displays all the current
parameter values being used
for the current model displayed the user
can also
hover over parts of these graphs to get
population values at the specific time
on the x axis
and then we included one final tab just
with some further information about the
processes
involved in this model so i'm also just
going to explain a little bit more about
how we
were able to use the bouquet package in
python to
include these interactive aspects in our
model
and so it's kind of a cycle and i'm just
going to include some of the code
snippets and talk you through
so the first step was setting up the
data and the initial conditions so this
code on the right is just
a bunch of the initial parameter values
we had to set
to have our base models to build off of
and then the code below
below is setting up the network graph so
creating all of the nodes and their
initial sizes
and location and creating the edges
between certain nodes
so the second step is plotting these
initial conditions like i mentioned
the infectious disease model is based
off a system of differential equations
so the solve ivp function solves this
system of differential equations over
the time span which we use
of 365 days um and
this stored each of the class will be
stored
in a vector um that includes each of
their
population values through the 365 days
in time
and then this here also includes setting
up the time
slider and setting the initial sizes
of the nodes
so then the last big aspect of this is
how the user can interact with the model
and the code
that supports that so this first
function on the right
update data bubble gets the current time
at the time slider and then retrieves
each of the eight
class populations at that given time and
updates the network grab and the bar
graph to display the current class
population
and then the next two functions on the
left here kind of deal with the pause
and play button
so the animate update function
automatically iterates through time so
it'll take a time
value display each of the eight class
populations accordingly
and then automatically move to the next
time unit and display those
again and again so then that's used
within
the animate function which calls
the animate update function to stop or
start iterating
when a user presses the pause or play
button
so as mentioned previously we do have
two other models currently being
provided on our website so this is the
um dashboard that one looks at when
you're doing the
reaction kinetics model so on the left
are the sliders where you can adjust the
different values and so the graphs
automatically update as well so it
allows you to basically see the
concentration over time
for two sequential reactions
the next model that we have is a model
for zero energy cooling chamber which is
a cheap and effective way
for storing food and it is um
based off of evaporative cooling that
passively cools food on
the inside of this chamber
so this is the dashboard that one would
look at bearing the zero energy cooling
chamber model
so with this you are able to view
data that we provide on the dashboard
and so students are able to kind of use
this
in while using the model to help
guide their decision making process
while using this
so as you can see there are sliders and
adjustable values and parameters and
then in the bottom there's a table where
you can tabulate
data and keep a record of
of each parameter value as you're
adjusting it
so in this process of making these
models we also took um
surveys of students to get an
understanding of how the user experience
was
so overall it was a very um positive
result that we received so the
overwhelming majority of people found
our models to be clear and useful and
they understood the meaning of it
and furthermore every single person who
we surveyed was actually able to access
the models as presented on the website
from the devices that they used
all right so thank you everyone for
listening to our talk today
we are excited and eager to answer any
questions or comments you may have about
the specific models or projects in
general in the q a portion of this talk
thank you